[Music]
this hit
goes out to you Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
And So It Begins
challenging into single combat if you
win you'll have your freedom
amen
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
and peace
[Music]
yeah not really
my name is Mills I was the pilot of this
ship with crash landed on an Uncharted
planet
we are the only survivors I don't know
where we are but there's something out
there
something alien
we must get to escape Festival Escape
yeah
oh
family
ready
run
[Applause]
okay okay
tell me something
you can go anywhere
[Music]
another Town Line
Another Universe
so why do you want to stay
fight to save this one
this is the world where my mom lives
I'm not gonna lose her again
[Music]
time has a pattern
that it can't help reliving
different people different worlds
drawn to each other with magnets
[Music]
it's my face so my face
if you were to go into the past
you have no idea what the consequences
can be Bruce I could fix things you
could also destroy everything
is happening
completely broke the universe
outside we've been waiting for you
created a world with no metahumans
and now there's no one to defend us
want some help
[Music]
here
you are yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
if I can undo what I did
if I can't get back
there might not be a future
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
it's not Clark
Miss Cara
foreign
Barry what are you doing our kids are
gonna want to see this
[Music]
oh
it was all a dream the name's Mirage
come on kill tap okay
relax a mirage remember
and if you don't know
I know that this road has been very hard
and yet here you are building This
Magnificent family
what's going on in that head of yours
something a little piece of it he said
dad they're not afraid of anything
but I am
afraid of losing someone I love
Dominic Toretto you're about to learn
all about fear
boom you built such a beautiful life
filled with love and family I never got
that chance
you stole that from me
my few
my family
and now
I'm gonna break yours
be by piece
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
no problem
he's trying to tear us apart
when it used to be about winning we
raced for respect
today I race to stop the blood back
[Music]
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
Let's Race
[Music]
[Applause]
you still know how to drive
what do you think
it's showtime
[Music]
recognizes game
I'm coming for you son
that's right
here they come you will never be able to
break my family
[Music]
good morning sunshine you gotta be
kidding me
[Music]
foreign
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
she came back a total dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
and want to make things perfect
you just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to if I decide my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
[Music]
your days of fighting for the so-called
greater good are over
this is our chance to control the truth
the concepts of right and wrong from
everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
foreign
[Music]
ER
we're rich boys
get down on your knees
[__] him up
we got gold
here is a finished Commander lost his
home and his family in the war he became
a one-man Death Squad
he's one mean [__] that you do
not want to mess with
[Music]
you'll see what happens when you take
everything from him
no he just refuses to die how many Minds
did you bury here all of them
you
and you
this is not about who's the strongest
this is about not giving up
we have a word for that in Finland
[Music]
you might have problem
the higher you get the harder it gets
[Music]
that's life
because this is a war
there's a fight it's a battle
so
how long have you known each other
[Music]
it was like brothers
my name came back the past came back too
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back no friends
[Music]
before I got locked up I was the best
power bro and a fraud
it's gonna have your life in the sale
watching somebody else live your life
it's not gonna stop then you make it
the one and only Adonis Creed you're the
best pound fighter in the world three
years ago it's been a minute since
you've been out in these streets when I
walked away from boxing I walked away
with some unfinished business
[Music]
you see that man right there
do you remember him hey hey
no friends in the industry
my brothers and my enemies
I'll let him destroy everything you
found
everything we've built
[Music]
you out there
start fighting
[Music]
we are a dwarf
we will annihilate everything
champions of this realm can do nothing
to stop us
you are very menacing I just want you to
know that
she's in the last few years the wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers
all right here's the situation
the daughters of Atlas are coming to
hunt us
let's talk the power of the Gods he
ripped it from our father's call okay I
feel like maybe I should be writing all
this down you lost the powers child your
world will not survive this
you want these Powers come get them hey
Khaleesi
in front of bottom now we're here all
right
we have one job to do save the world
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I can't do this take my powers back you
came to me so you would take them back
right
searching for worthy champion
you know exactly what must be done
really what are you doing I have to do
this we end this now
we do
that's how we're here
[Music]
foreign
what's the job we're gonna destroy their
own nuclear program
breaking news exposing the cia's
sabotage Iran's nuclear reactor covers
blood we're leaving 15 minutes
stretching point and
[Music]
the distance is not the main issue
that's what's in between
they didn't even catch my guys I'll sell
them to the highest bidder
[Music]
no one is coming to rescue us
we have to get to kandor
foreign
as a private contractor you're
possessing a unique set of skills
[Music]
you said it was clear I said the front
was clear
ah front back right wrong anyway shall
we I have another job for you so what we
got Greg Simmons the billionaire arms
dealer oh a lot very serious faces up
here in there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures I'm sorry The
Lure being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law I actually loved my
sister-in-law
[Music]
you're an actor Act
with someone pinch me please is that
Danny Francesca what's next for you I'm
playing a mysterious self-made
billionaire he just described me shadow
mate do whatever I do whatever I do do
whoever Crick was buying from I was
amongst you last night
I can get inside of them
I hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
what happens you recognized your awesome
fortune that is a sexy name covers blown
what do I do the movie star's gonna melt
she stopped any Francesca
you let me worry about that
what are you gonna do with that I'm
gonna shoot at them Danny
oh
so you weren't seen by anyone yes that's
a yes you weren't seen by anyone yes or
yes you were seen by someone yes
everybody
John we have tallies approaching
[Music]
you still don't remember a thing I don't
remember any of it
I only remember
The Interpreter
[Music]
well he wants this job I need the money
don't disappoint turn out to be a pain
in the ass no not me sir
money isn't the reason he wants this job
and Taliban killed his son
stop the vehicle starting we don't want
to go down this road you're out of your
bounds Ahmed you're here to translate
actually I'm here to interpret John you
up Tally's approaching
[Music]
for three weeks this family believed you
were dead we owe that man your life if
it wasn't enough for him to carry me
across those mountains
[Music]
no he's hiding in a hole somewhere I
should be in that hole
everything all right John no
everything's not all right there is a
hook in me
Ahmed and his family are in trouble we
can't intervene
I get him out myself
listen you're gonna be alone
you gotta went down
here's what you got
if you can give me the location if I can
get them out of the country it's too
dangerous
you become very popular with the Taliban
I miss you love you Daddy
if I could be free of this debt I
wouldn't be
you'd think I have a choice
there is no choice no I Won't
Back Down
my memory is a little fuzzy are you
still a Nazi
[Music]
doing here
on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
oh we got him now
you know what I'm thinking they're
probably sharper stairs somewhere else
we're thieves but we help the wrong
person steal the wrong thing and unleash
the greatest evil the world has ever
known
the red Wizards created an army of the
undead
sounds lovely quite the opposite I know
I was being ironic I find irony as a
blade because he who wields it most
especially you're not a lot of fun are
you how are we gonna pull this off we're
gonna need a team
the orifice
I'll go lost
she missed
no that's not good
aren't you sick of failing we could die
it's worse things than dying
foreign
ever mattered to me and if we quit now
that's for nothing I don't want to see
you die which is why I'm Gonna Leave the
Room
the bridge is protected by an ancient
trap we must not trigger the mechanism
I may have triggered the mechanism
so
sorry
I'm Ria Khan I am going to be a stock
woman
[Music]
my sister Lena is the only person who
believes in me want to help me with the
vid for my Channel please
please
she helped me with all my training you
are going to be such a great stumbler
foreign
[Music]
but lately she's been seeing this guy
who I think is a bit of a smarmy wanker
you know it's a truck oh my God Ria
chill out now I'm not being dramatic
but these people are evil
I found something
I put my eye on you they are not taking
her away without a fight
I will strike down you or anyone else
who tries to get in my way
how about the bikini area
Let's Dance
we need to get Lena out
how Mischief is a foot
Mila's not going anywhere you little
[__]
mom what are you doing now
[Music]
mistakes
nothing changes
we are going to show Rina who these
people really are
y'all calling me crazy
did you see my kick of course I bloodied
it it was magical
so I drew blood
[Music]
what do you want looks like he could use
a little excitement in your life have
all the excitement I need right here how
about a challenge high stakes
I'm in this job is not like any other
job
what are we stealing
a painting
four paintings wait what it's the most
beautiful art the world has ever known
each one of you is the best at what you
do
[Music]
the paintings we're getting back were
stolen by Nazis during World War II so
not a standard smashing ground Who's
Gonna Get Us killed
you will never get my paintings so
what's the play these guys are dangerous
we just need them incapacitated not hurt
I can do it I know a little hang stuff
one at the next stop will be our last we
got a problem
under control
what are we walking into here
holy that's not a safe that's a fault
it's cool it's awesome love it
we're trying to right a wrong Against
Humanity this one tell me what the hell
is going on this this is bigger than us
what's happening to us they know we're
coming
you know what they used to do to save
some Nazi Germany
oh
oh hold up hold up is that nuclear
[Music]
in days of Legend
gods
walk the earth
[Music]
say it what have I told you
Cena had returned in human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
[Music]
thank you
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just hard to see my little man not
be my little boy all the time
yeah
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you miles
it was they won't look out for you like
us
miles
wanna get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
have to promise to take care of that
little boy for me
make sure he never forgets where he came
from
[Music]
and
he never doubts that he's loved
[Music]
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
[Music]
thank you